كان هناك قريه تدعى الطنطوره ولكن قبل 75
عاما وبالتحديد في الثالث والعشرين من
مايو ايار
احتلتها عصابات صهيونيه وارتكبت بدم بارد
مجازر جماعيه راح ضحيتها اكثر من 200 شخص
تلك العصابات كانت تدعى الهاجانا ارتكبت
المجزره قبل ايام فقط من تغيير اسمها الى
جيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي الان وبعد عام ونصف
عام من جهود التوثيق والتحقيق التي قامت
بها اللجنه اهالي الطنطوره ومركز عداله
ومؤسسه فروزنك اركيتكشر الدوليه صدر تقرير
يحدد اماكن المقابر الجماعيه
ويوثق شهادات لناجينا من المجزره تحدث
الشهود عن مقاومه شرسه للفلسطينيين
ومجازر بشعه نفذها الاسرائيليون
نعم نعم
ياخذوهم على مسافه عشرين متر هيك دخلات
تبع الحاره يرشوهم
باثناء شيعه زمان ساعتين زمان قتلوا بطلع
60 سبعين شهر يضم التقرير مواد ارشيفيه
وخرائط وصور القريه الواقعه جنوبي مدينه
حيفا تبلغ مساحه اراضي الطنطوره نحو
14,520 دونم وقدر عدد سكانها في عام
1945 بنحو
1490 نسمه قبل ان تهجم العصابات الصهيونيه
المسلحه القريه
وتشرد اهلها الصور الجويه التي التقطت قبل
عام
تؤكد وجود مقبره تاريخيه في قلب قريه
النحشوليم على انقاض قريه الطنطوره حيث
اقيمت منتجعات سياحيه وبنا تحتيه لطمس
المعالم وكل ما يش على وقوع المجزره حدد
المشاركون في التحقيق المقبره الجماعيه
الاولى التي تحولت الى مراى بسيارات تابعا
لمنتجع على شاطئ جنوب مدينه حيفا ولم يعد
للمقبره اي اثر فيما تقع المقبره الجماعيه
الثانيه داخل المنتجع الموقع الثالث
للمقابر الجماعيه كان وراء بيت عائلتي
يحيى البيت الوحيد الباقيه اثاره من
القريه اما المقبره الجماعيه الرابعه
فكانت بمحاذاه المقبره التاريخيه للقريه
وفقا للجنه التحقيق فان من شان هذا
التقرير ان يؤسس لمسار قانوني بهدف الحصول
على اعتراف اسرائيل بالمجزره وفرض احترامي
وحرمه تلك المقابر الجماعيه بما يسمح لذوي
ضحايا الطنطوره بدف ن احبتهم كما يليق بهم
لتضمد ربما جراح لم تهجع لخمسه وسبعين
عاما